hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason io
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
one of the things that's that's
particularly distinctive to rene
descartes approach to philosophy
which you see not only in his his book
the discourse on method but also in
other of his his works
is in fact having some sort of
method and advocating that
is central to how to do not only
philosophy but how to approach
other problems in which you want to make
progress
and the cart lays out a
four-step process that he calls the the
rules of method
in in
section two or part two rather of the
the discourse on method now this is
something that descartes follows in in
the rest of his works as well so it's
sort of a lens by which we can get an
idea of the cartesian project
so if you're approaching descartes for
the first time
or if you're you know approaching him
later on and just coming back to this
material it's often useful to
you know
to make a pun meditate upon these these
four rules that descartes sets out
what i want to do in this video
is first of all um talk about how these
these fit into his larger ideas and then
go through each one of these
and then
talk about how descartes work actually
follows these steps
and then
if time permits actually you know maybe
look at a few examples of how you might
apply this
so
why does descartes have rules of method
in the discourse
and he also says things like this in
some of his other works
descartes seems to hold the view that
we're all equally rational we all have
the same basic capacities as human
beings
to carry out reasoning and like he says
the only reason why we actually differ
from one another when it comes to the
conclusions of our reasoning
is because we start from different
starting points
and we conduct our minds
differently we don't always do things in
a systematic
careful
methodical way
so his idea is that if in fact we were
to
start with the right starting points
and which is really what the the first
one is about and even the second one to
a certain degree and then conduct our
minds in the right way if we were to
proceed systematically carefully
according to a right method
we would eventually get to
truth
and truth that we could be completely
certain about
that's descartes
big project he wants to
find things that he can be absolutely
certain about
convinced about
not put into doubt any further so that
then he can reapply this method so
that's that's the big picture of why
he's doing this so let's look at these
rules one at a time then
so the first one except nothing is true
that i don't clearly know to be true and
then a little bit later he says clearly
and distinctly and this is a a central
criteria for descartes clear and
distinct knowledge of things
clearly
means that
it's very difficult to describe this
without going into sort of circular
things clearly means it's very clear to
you clearly means that you can bring it
up before your mind and you can you can
examine it not necessarily in terms of
pictures because that would be
imagination but in terms of the concepts
or the ideas themselves
and
they they strike you as as being true
it's not just that you feel that they're
true you can give some sort of account
for why that is why that is so
distinctly you can actually distinguish
these ideas that you have
apart from other ideas that might
actually be similar close to
uh confused with with them
this is the the cartesian
sort of touchstone the criteria for
things
and as you see him going through his
works he says certain things are clear
and distinct and other things turn out
not to be clear and distinct so except
nothing is true
except what i can be really sure about
you know
completely sure
well you know when we get to practical
applications like this maybe not
completely sure maybe then we have to
have what descartes calls moral
certainty rather than metaphysical
certainty
but this is the standard that we ought
to be shooting for
so
that gives us our starting points
then
when we have a problem
what we want to do is we want to break
the problem down
into
all of its parts and we want to examine
each of those
parts
independently so the second one is about
dividing each problem into its
constituent parts
if we want to understand say an
automobile let's understand each part of
the automobile before we try putting it
all together
and then trying to make sense of it if
we want to understand a political
process of
give and take and compromise we want to
look at each individual agent and each
issue that they're interested in and
break each one of those down and try to
see if we can arrive at clear and
distinct knowledge of each one see if we
can be completely sure about each of
those
before we start proceeding on so we want
to
and we want to carry out a process of
analysis we want to break things down
that's what analysis means it's coming
from the greek words
leucine
to to break down
you know there's an intensifier in that
case now once we've actually broken
things down into their their
their parts their problems we've
distinguished things apart from each
other
then we want to
work at the problems in a sort of order
what do we want to start with the
simplest parts first the things that we
can we can
probably do the best in in
achieving some sort of
certainty or some sort of knowledge with
and then we want to slowly build our way
back upwards we don't want to be too
hasty the cartesian way of going at
things is to you know distinguish things
apart from each other and then look at
each part separately try to figure it
out then start putting them together and
you know you could actually say well the
cart you're leaving something out
sometimes the whole is greater than the
parts descartes doesn't uh
in terms of his method he doesn't worry
about that there's a certain commitment
that comes with this
that may not be amenable to every sort
of problem
but we're only looking at the cart's own
view of this right now we're not
worrying about criticizing it at this
point
so we work at each problem in order
starting with the simplest parts and
hopefully we build our way up to
understand a complex whole
then the fourth part
is basically keep track of what you're
doing
he talks about you know making complete
enumerations or calculations
carrying out a general review
that's a good idea but what it really
boils down to is keep track of what you
actually did so that when you want to
know
what happened and what you understood
you can go back to it and look it up or
if somebody else
remember we're all supposed to share the
same rationality if somebody else wants
to go back to it they can they can go
through each one of these steps
themselves they can see that you know
well this is these are the premises that
we started with these are the starting
points these are the principles
these are the the elements that we broke
things down into here's how we put the
elements together we synthesized them
after we we fully understood them they
can follow through the process
that's something
descartes thinks it's very important
it's also important
so that if you screw something up you
can go back and you can check your work
you can figure out hey what what part
did i not put together right maybe it
was accepting something that you were
kind of hazy about that you didn't
really have clear knowledge of as being
true
maybe it was some background assumption
you didn't even realize you were you
were making as an assumption you know
you again that would be accepting
something that you didn't have good
grounds to accept
perhaps it could be that you didn't
divide things up as fully as you needed
to
or perhaps when you were dividing you
actually divided too far
you you broke things down that didn't
need to be broken down because they
weren't actually problematic could be
that when you're putting things together
you you uh didn't do it right you know
for instance when i was a kid i used to
take things apart an awful lot and i
could tell i was not going to be a
mechanic because i would always have
spare parts left over we called spare
parts meaning parts that actually
belonged to the thing that i had broken
down and then put back together that i i
didn't put back in the right place
well if i'd actually kept track of what
i was doing then you know follow this
cartesian process i would be able to go
back and say aha this fits in here
unfortunately when it comes down to it
personally i'm not a very good person
for following the instructions i'd
rather just throw it together
so
does dickhard apply this and only this
in the course of his works
no there's more going on to descartes
project than just this
but this is sort of the general outline
of what he's up to
and
you know he is really about
clear and distinct knowledge he is
really about distinguishing dividing and
then trying to solve each thing
separately so when for example you see
him saying the body is something
completely different than mind you know
one is extended one is not extended one
is is simple the other is complex
what he's doing is he's taking a problem
the problem of what a human being is
breaking it down into its constituent
parts
breaking the body further down into its
constituent parts and then trying to
analyze them on that basis and then put
them back together he always had some
difficulty in explaining just exactly
how the mind in the body
did interact but that's a whole
different topic
making the complete enumerations in
general review that's what you see
descartes actually doing in the
discourse on method
in the meditations and in his other
works like you know the the principles
which are much less read by by beginners
in in philosophy but more by by
descartes scholars
so descartes is applying all of this in
his philosophy you know for example
when he is engaging in hyperbolic doubt
something that i'll shoot another video
on
that's really stressing accepting
nothing is true that he doesn't know to
be true
and he's also breaking things down and
he's saying well i can doubt this and i
can doubt this and i can doubt this and
i can doubt this but i can't doubt this
he's able to do that because he's made
good
distinctions then when he starts putting
things back together again which is what
he does which is what he is his project
really is it's not just doubting
everything his project is putting
everything back together
the the human being the mind the self
you know the mind and the body together
the world other beings other other human
beings god all these things he's trying
to put them all back together in some
sort of coherent scheme
that's what's going on in three and and
four in his work
now
let's say that you actually wanted to
apply this very rigorously in your own
life and you didn't want to just use
descartes examples
what might you do
well
you could think about mechanical
problems
you want to solve
something being broken right
you
then go to this step right away
try to figure out well of course you
don't want to you know just accept
hazy knowledge or not knowledge about
what is the conditions you actually want
to look at things but you want to
isolate the problem
and then engage in some sort of
diagnostic
right
um
once you've done that you can work at
figuring out how to put the things back
together and make it run
descartes seems to think that we could
do this in just about anything mechanics
is very similar he thinks to medicine
which is very similar to
the way morality ought to work his
classic 3ms
if we want to think about social
problems a cartesian would actually
focus on society as being an aggregate
of individuals
which then
enter into complexes with each other
perhaps you know groups families
relationships things like that
and you would want to look at each
individual separately and then want to
look at how they come together
and you would want to be as clear as
possible at each step you wouldn't want
to just only look at a group
and generalize
about people individuals on the basis of
that group you would want to look at
each individual
separately
as a unit
again you would want to carry out
general reviews of things you would want
to keep track of what it is that you're
doing
so
hopefully this gives you a good
grounding in what descartes four rules
of method are that he talks about in the
discourse and now you have some idea
about how you might apply these how
these fit in with descartes project
and what in fact each of these four
rules are so just to sum up except
nothing is true that you don't know
clearly to be true you're looking for
clear and distinct knowledge divide each
problem up into its elements its
constituent parts carry out a process of
analysis
work at the at the problems that you've
got in an order starting with the
simplest things building your way up to
more and more complex holes complex
unities
and understanding those on the basis of
their constituent
parts finally make complete enumerations
keep complete reports make sure you
didn't leave anything out do a a quick
check of your own work review your
processes
and make sure that you could explain it
to somebody else